Yle Areena.
(musiikkia)
Heija tässä Sysmästä taas. Morjesta. Semmosta ilosta uutista tässä vaan, että tuli eläkkeyhtiöltä kirje, jossa mainittiin, että eläkke nousee hukunaisen.
Nolla pilkku seitsytkahdeksan prosenttia, mikä minun lausakelmieni mukaan tekee kuukaudessa peräti yhdeksän pilkku kolmekymmentä kuusi euroa, joten kyllä nyt eläkeläisten ostovoima nousee, kun viippuu kohti jää vähän päälle kaksi euroa. Kyllä tällä nyt mällätään, että kiitokset vaan päättäjille. Oin, moi.
Esi on luvassa ohjelmassa myöhemmin. Jälleen on aika todeta perinteisesti, eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Tällä kertaa puoli tuntissa käsitellään ainakin luontoa, liikkumista ja sote-teemoja. Monia muitakin aiheita on toki myös tarjolla. Tämän jakson osaset on vääntänyt jingoilleen Koiviston Lauri. Yksi kansalainen kertoo alkoholin kotiinkuljetuksen olevan osa sote-uudistusta. Toinen taas en kertoa, että hiihtiö.
Lopputulossa voitaisiin arpoa norjalaista mitallistit ja ehdotetaanpa kuntoilijoiden ladulle hiihtovahteakin. Nyt on työllisyyskatsauksen aika. Malmo Valtilainen työllisyyskatsaus. Työttömyyden kasvuvauhdin kiihtymisen, vauhdin hidastuminen olisi jo sinällään iso helpotus. Elikkä jos saadaan toppuuteltua tätä vauhtia, millä.
Työttömyyden lisääntyminen kiihtyy, niin ollaan paremman tien alussa. Näin katsomalla puolelta seuraa tätä työllisyyskautta työttömyystilannetta ja huonolta on näyttänyt, mutta saattaa hyvinkin olla käännettä parempaan tulossa ennen seuraavaa huonoa vaihetta. Hyvää sunnuntain jatkoa. Kiitoksia.
Kiitos Maunolle Jyväskylään. Kovin pitkälle ei maantieteellisesti siirrytä seuraavaksi, kun tiemme vie Sysmään. Luvassa on laajasti sanottuna luontoa ja liikkumista.
Tulee niin kauheasti haukkuja. Tuli jo koiran kakka haukkuja tuossa, mikä oli mutta ihan hyvä. Kelkkähän ei voi sanoa yhtään mitään Suomessa. Otetaan vähän isompi näkökulma tässä kun kuuntelee, että mitä hiistoladuilla niin se on aika hirvittävää, että kuudetaan ja ollaanko Euroopan omistajat siellä mukamas. Koko latu tunnetaan ja sinä menet väärään suuntaan ja sinä menet oikeaan.
Siis aivan järjetentä. Sehän on ihan naurettavaa. On yhteisiä latuja kaikki hiihtäjille. Millä tätä tilannetta voisi parantaa? Sillä, että miettii omaa tunnetasoa ja myöskin mä oon miettinyt, että sinne pitäisi laittaa hiihtovahtaja. Hiihtovahtaja? Kyllä, elikkä palkataan sinne hiihtämään sitten porukkaa ja sitten nää ketpoisella koko ajan aukosuutaa ja päätää. Niin laitetaan niitä parannuksia.
Eli jonkunlaisia järjestysvalvoja? Juu, koska näitähän on mittu tuolla jo rinti. Siis näitähän on laittu kaatoa rinteisiin. Kiitoksia Minna tästä ehdotuksesta. Hiihtovahtaja kun on rinnevahtajat. Hei!
Ja sitä kautta nurmialueet on vähän huolissani, että miten ne kestää ravinteiden puolesta tämän säiden ääriolosuhteita ja sitä kautta nurmikkohan voi parhaiten silloin kun sitä lannoitetaan. Ja mitä minä on pannut Merkille ihan nurmialueiden kuntoakin katsellessa, että kaupunki ei hirveästi panosta tuohon nurmialueiden ja puistojen lannoittamiseen. Ja sitä kautta minun mielestä voidaan kaikki osallistua ja kaikki koirat, koska koiran kakka on loistavaa.
Ja sitä kautta kaikki koirat sinne puistikoihin ja ei kerätä niitä niihin pussoihin jotka kuormittaa luontoa. Ja sitä kautta kannetaan kortemmat kekoon tähän nurmialueiden lannoitusasia. Tämmösiä ideoja heitä ilman. Ei muuta kuin hyvää kevättä kaikille tosikoille ja veitikkoille.
Miten tiedotusvälineissä haastattelija kiittää haastateltavaa ja haastateltava kiittää takaisin? Eikö suomalaisempi tapa vastata olisi ole hyvä, olkaa hyvä? Kiitos on Amerikasta levinnyt tapa, joka on rantautunut myös meille ja särähtää pilkuttajan korvaan ikävästi. Vähän löylyä lisää kun haastateltava vastaa ole hyvä voisi haastattelija vastata yritän olla.
Jossa ei ole mitään nimeä mukana. Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio.yt. Yle piste fi tässä ristopuustinen peräpunavuoresta ei. Hei hei. On näkyvänmainen, että tästä Helsingin kaupungin jutuslaitetta ollaan poistamassa. Ensinnä sinä tainikin nappi niin kuin siitä, että pääset ylistämään tietoja. Se on kerran jos olisi äänimerkki niin liikennevaloista. Niin ja niitä on aika harvassa.
Ja kun katsoo ydinkeskustaa niin missä on liikennevaloita? Aika harva se on, mutta äänimäkki toimii tai toimii. Se on jos katsoo suoraan jos Suomen pääkatu eli Mannerheimin tie niin lasipalatsin kohdalla on kunnan äänimärkit, mutta siten ratikkapisakin toisella puolella niin kuin foorumin kuluessa ei toimi äänimärkit. Bulevarda ei toimi äänimerkkejä, ei toimi monesta kohtaa. Keskellä kaupunki ei toimi äänimärkit. Ja minulla periaatteessa peräpunavuoreessa Kampio on.
valoristeista, jos on punaiset ja vihreät valot ja en erota niitä. Tosiaan pitää vaan mennä sattumanmukaisesti niistä yli. Onneksi niin vähän onneksi. Ja sitten voi aina seurata ihmisiä jotka kokevat päinpunaisia.
Eli vahva toiveesi on että liikennevalojen äänimerket pitäisi hoitaa kuntoon? Kyllä. Jos on Suomen pääkaupunki ja keskustassa ei toimi tälläistä asiat niin ja sille mietitään vielä että ne painikemerkit jos on esimerkiksi Itäkeskustan lähellä Itäkeskuksen metroasemaa kun on sille väylälle kohti Iiriskeskusta on esimerkiksi sellaiset painat että pääset ylittämään niin ne tullaan poistamaan.
Sellaiset painikenapit. Niin miten se toimii jatkossa sitten kun siinä on kuitenkin sen verran vähemmän niin siellä on jalakulkijoita siinä keskellä siinä metroasemalta väylä yli sinne kohti Iiriskeskus tai Itäkeskuksen niin miten tällaiset asiat toimii sitten jatkossa? Mutta tosiaan se pääasia on se että jos on valot ylipäätä niin pitäisi olla myös äänimerkkin. Kiitoksia paljon tästä soitosta ja mukava asunonta jatkoa. No niin kiitos. Moi moi.
Vinkki ja idea tulevaisuutta varten. Pitäisi perustaa puutarhoja enemmän omakotitellut tonteille kasvattaa omeniasiat ja omenahilloja kesän aikaa syötävän erilaisia omenalaatuja ja myös marjapenssaita, punaista punaista viinimariaa, mustaviinimariaa ja sitten karvijaisia ja muita erilaisia hedelmapuita ja samaten myös voistutaan niitä että sitten saa talvesta syötävää ja juotavaa ja mehujilta kaikki ja muita tällaisia. Suomen kansa olet unohtunut tämän vanhan hyväntämään koko ajan pois.
Omenapuut voi peittää puolitoimetriliaa korkeilla tuomisilla verkoilla ja myydään tuomisia verkkoja tuoma metallialan myyntiliikkeessä jossa on semmoista se on tätä betoniverkkoa puolitoimetriliaa korkeilla niin ei pääset kuitenkaan jäniksi et syömään niitä. Ja sen takia on tärkeää että myös kunnissa, olissa kaupungissa olisi puutarhanpalveluja joka kaupungissa että ihmiset voisivat harrastaa ulkona liikkumista ja ulkotyöskentelyä. Oma puutarhanhoito on myös se on fyysistä se on mielenterveydellistä se on terveydellistä se on hapeensaannille hyvä.
Ja paljon muuta luonnonmukaista toimii tämä enemmän ihmisten parhaaksi.
Iltapäivä. Mä ihmettelen kun tässä just äsken soitti Kansanradioo yks mies joka kehui Starran hoitamia kattuja tänä talvena niin olisi kiva tietää mistäkö hän päihän soitti Helsingistä.
Tietysti kun Starra hoitaa tai vaan Helsingistä mutta kyllä minä sanon ainakin että minun mielestäni ei ole niin paljon taas vaihteen nyt kyllä tää oli perän jälkeen että ei ole kyllä hyvin hoidettu päivän jatkoa.
Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella no tupakat ei saa näkyä niin miksi kaljat lonksut sidukat ynnä muut ovat reilusti kaupoissa esillä. Onko tupakat vaarallisempia. Esimerkiksi niille jotka yrittää päästä eroon alkosta. Pitäisi olla suojaseinä alue alkojuomille. Tämä teksti oli lähdetty Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella. Sen oli kirjoittanut nimimerkki sakun.
No reino pikkuinen palkamassa päivää. Päivää päivää. Tuossa kun kuuntelin sen Kansanradion niin siellä yksi yhdellä naisella oli hyvä kysymys niin minulla olisi siihen vastaus. Se sanoi siihen aineen että mitä vasten mieheltä tukka lähtee ja naiselta ei lähe. Niin kaliuntuminen. Niin vastaus on että tyhjä lato ei kattoa tarvitse. No niin joo tämä on aika hyvä vastaus monelle. Selvä juttu kiitoksia paljon tästä. Ole hyvä hei hei hei.
no se on skinheadscari tältä parasiot morjesta tässä kuunneltiin teidän tota yöohjelmaa ja se verta oli noita muun muassa
vegetarian hernekketta soppasyöjiä ja sun muita niin kyllähän se vaan niin on se asia että kyllä terveen suomalaisen miehen ja naisen pitää vähintään syödä viikossa kaks kiloa nauden jauhelihaa höystettynä kermalla ja voilla. et jos sitä ei syö niin on vähintään säilyttävää työtä.
pikkasen päästään kajahtanut eikä ymmärrä oman kansantalouden eikä huoltovarmuuden eikä puhtaan suomalaisen ruuan puolesta yhtään mitään puhumattakaan punaisesta maidosta tai tankkimaidosta mitä hyvin valituista ruokakaupoista saa ja no siis ihan ihmevouhottajia löytyy kyllä tähän linjaan ja toivon että jokainen nyt kuuntelee ja menee huomenna kauppaan ostamaan.
nauden jauhelihaa ja punaista maitoa. morjes!
Se tarvittais myös sitä, että vaalipiiristä niin käytännössä katsoen aina tulisi valituksi suurimman puolueen, kaksi ehdokasta ja muitten puolueitten yksi ehdokas. Tällaisen pienentyen eduskunnan puolueen jakauma tällä nykyisellä vaalisysteemillä, elikkä korkein vertailulukuun, niin sillä päästään sitten aina eduskuntaa järjestyksessä. Niin olisi suunnilleen niin, että perussuomalaiset viisitoista paikkaa, kokoomus kolmetoista paikkaa, SDP kaksitoista paikkaa. Sitten nämä pienemmät keskusta kuusi RKP.
kaksi vihreät, kaksi vasemmasta liitto, kaksi. Tarkoittaisi siis sitä, että noista kolmesta suurista puolueista, niin aina kaksi pitäisi valita ja sitten niille kelpaisi mikä tahansa, sitten muu puolue tukipuolueeksi. Eli meille tulisi tällaiset hallitukset. Sitä itse koki mietti, että olisiko se hyvä vai huono asia.
Siinä Lille kuljetti meidät kotimaan kysymysten äärelle. No, Pohjanmaan onko tältä? Tätä velkajarrua on ihmetellyt, että mitä -
tässä on asettaa järru juuri nyt kun velka on aivan tapissa. Tiedän kyllä paljon politiikkaa seuranneena, että tämä on oikeistostahtinen siirto. Tällä siirralla estetään loivempi velan tasapainoitus ja leikkaukset jatkuvat myös seuraavassa hallituksessa. Tämä velkajarru olisi pitänyt tehdä jo viisitoista vuotta sitten. Yleensä jarrua painotetaan -
ennen kolaria. Ei hyödytä painaan jos on jo kolissut. Ja vanha sanonta sanoo, että ei kannata pyllittää jos on jo paskat housuus. Ja näille jotka ovat hoitaneet maan talouden tällaisen kuntoon, tekisi mieleni sanoa kun Kekkonen aikoinaan hallitukselle, että saatanan tunarit. - No nyt on aika punnita sanat ja teot. Onko?
- Lait ja määräykset samanlaisia kaikille. Nimittäin. Tietääkseni Suomessa on käytäntö, että teknisillä laitteilla ei tehdä kauppaa sotaa käyviin maiden kanssa. Ja tällä hetkellähän USA on sotaa käyvä maa. Ei siitä päästä mihinkään yli eikä ympäri. Riehuu ympäri maapalloa. Niin miten tämä jäänmurtaja kauppa? Voidaanko se nyt tehdä tässä tilanteessa vai?
- Onko se raha joka tässä ratkaisee? On meinään aika isoista rahoista kysymys. Tämmöisiä tässä tuumaa olevia Veka pälkäneeltä.
Tulee yksi eläjähautaus niin kalliiksi kunnan, että sitä viimeistä matkaa odotetaan.
Näiden kiitosten jälkeen on luontevaa siirtyä kuuntelemaan tämänkertainen annos soteteemaisia puheluita. Aloitamme aiheen WhatsApp-viestillä, jossa lukee näin:
Kiitän ja toivon, että tämä jatkuu esimerkiksi kolme kertaa vuodessa voisi käydä tämänkaltaisen toiminnan puitteissa lääkärissä. Suuri kiitos kevättä odotellessa.
- No Markkuli, terve. - Terve, terve. - Eikö mä ole tos joulujäätille kun se on vähän huonos kun mä oon itse kuuskytkuusvuotias. Siille nyt tuli nää digitaaliporuka tai nää ranneketia näin, mutta se ei saanut mitään ohjeita. - Siis joku tämmönen turvaranneket -tyyppinen? - Joo kun sille käy se hautteellisia ysikymppisille muijallekin pitäisi jotenkin vaikuttaa. - Siis joku tämmönen turvaranneket -tyyppinen? - Joo kun sille käy se hautteellisia ysikymppisille muijallekin pitäisi jotenkin vaikuttaa.
neuvo se miten ne toimii. Mutta mitään ei neuvottu? Ei ja sitten kun mä olin siinä ja siis ojan mun veli oli siinä. Jumala sanoi no mä luo töpseli seinään ja painoo sitä. Kyllä se nyt joku vastaa. No miten kävi? Ni sit niin niitä ei olekaan päivitetty tänne ollenkaan. Meinaa just leidessä kun luitkata kun joku ykstoista kertaa painaa no ja liikkuu. No selvisikö se teidän kohdallaan?
Joo nythän se on sitten niin hyvin innostunut joku oppinusta käyttää että mut se että kun sitä pitäs saada sitä niinku käyttöohjeita niinku tiedät ja se on nyt näköjään täällä niinku tuussa Lastjärven päässeet tuolla niin siis neuvoa mun ei unohtuu niinku kokonaan. Ja mutta hienoa kun sinä nostit tämän asian esille. Toivottavasti jatkossa sujuu paremmin. Joo kiitos moi.
Hei vaan kaikki kansasarjan kuuntelijat olen aika ällistynyt seurasin tässä televisiosta vammaisilta lapsilta otetaan rahaa pois minuikkaan se on päässy hiukan liikkumaan eikö mitään muuta mahdollisuutta ole jos ei ole vanhukset tai lapset niin sit on tällaiset vammaiset. Eduskunta saisi hävetä siellä on puoli.
Hyvässä oli aina torstaisin kun katsomme sitä. Raat pois heiltä ja antakaa niille jotka tarvitse. Hyvää päivänjatkoa kaikille kansalaisille. Hei hei.
No voidaan vitalsi rikosten tekijöillä on ilmaista täysihoitoa. Heidän terveyden hoidon riittämättömyydestä ollaan huolissaan kun samanaikaisesti suljetaan vuodeosasto.
Ja elätetään maahanmuuttajia että onpa hyvin asia tässä Suomen tasavallassa vai onko tää minkäänlainen tasa. Ei muuta kuin kaikkea hyvää. Koitetaan jaksaa tavallinen kansa. Moikka.
Ja kun on alkuun päästy niin antaa mennä vaan kuten aikoinaan Veksi kirjoitti tai siis Emil Rete eli sote aiheen parissa riittää vielä kommentoita vaan. Ennen äänimuotoisia ajatuksia tämä kirje ärsyttää. Onko näillä naisilla huono muisti kun monta kertaa illassa mainostavat emätin ja vakina kuivuutta. Voisitteko mennä muistitestiin. Jos alapää kuivuu niin jokainen osaa sitä huomauttaa.
Voidaan hoitaa tai mennä lääkäriin. Tällä tavoin lukee kirjeessä joka on saapunut meille Kansanradio on ilman nimeä. Meille voi laittaa kortta ja muuta perinteistä postiaosoitteeseen. Kansanradio pl seitsemänkymmentäyhdeksän nolla nolla nolla kaksikymmentäneljä Yleisradio.
Yksi mummo liikin 90. Tässä yksin ollessani olen mietiskellyt tätä alkoholin kotiinkuljetusta. Sehän on ihan selvästi osa sote-uudistusta. Kun nyt nämä hoivaavailla olevat vanhukset voisivat tilata Alkon tuotteita helposti potiin, eikä edes iän määrittely olisi mitenkään vaikeata, niin ei varmaan hirveän pitkiä aikoja kuruisi, kun jo vanhusten määrä alkaisi totaalisesti pudota.
Eikä hoitopaikoista sen jälkeen olisi mitään pulaa. Kiitoksia.
Poi silmistä. Ehkä ajatellaan niin. Kyllä sivistysvaltiossa tulee julkinen hoitopaikka olla jokaisellekin tarvitse. Sen he ovat työllä ansainneet. Onhan häpeä ettemme toimi niin. Vuoro tulee kullekin ajallaan. Hyvää kevättä. Terveisin Olavi.
Oli seuraavanlainen meny. Aamiaiseksi kaurapuuro, lounaaksi riisipuuro, veteen keitettynä ystävälleni, koska hän on maitoallergikko ja juomaksilla mukillinen vettä päivälliseksi mannavelle. Onkohan tämän menyn laatinut oikein geriatrisen ravitsemustieteeseen vartta vasten erikoistunut ravitsemusterapio? Hyvää ruokahalua kai. Hei hei.
Omaava sote-ammattilainen tätä Rovanin, että hei. Ihmettelen vaan sitä, että nykyäänkin on tällasta hierarkista työpaikka, jähmeyttä ja suoranaisista ehkä työpaikkakiusaamistakin.
Itselläni aika pitkä kokemus tukipalvelusta ja olen ollut monenlaisissa työpaikoissa, niin tällaiset epäviralliset käytänteet työpaikoille kyllä minua pistää suunnuttamaan.
Kyllä jos on jotain jostain sovittu, niin kyllä se pitäisi pitää kiinni ja sitten ei kun luistaa sillain niistä asioista. Monesti sote-alallani näkee nykyäänkin tällaisia epävirallisia käytänteitä ja ne pistää kyllä mielityttämään, miten voi olla, että olen ollut monenlaisissa sote-alan paikoissa.
Ihmetyttää kyllä ja ammatti ryhmien välillä on tätä skismoa, joillakin toimii paremmin ja joillakin huonommin, mutta tässä tapauksessa negatiivisesti itse yllätyin, että kuinka huonosti tukipalvelu työntekijöitä kohdellaan työpaiko. Kiitos.
Puheluita edeltää sähköposti. Olympialaiset tuli ja meni. Kritiikkiä on aiheuttanut sananlausuminen. Ihan sama meitsille, mutta haluan kiittää Yleä hyvästä kattauksesta. Erikois kiitos lätkän kommentaattoreille, Kojolle ja Jusalle. Rauhallista faktaa todellisilta ammattilaisilta, ei mitään ylimääräistä huutoa tai hehkutusta. Tämän sähköpostin meille oli kirjoittanut nimen Markki Lexa.
Semmoinen homma, että tää nainen, joka puhun osta näistä aika ajoista tässä hiilossa, on hänen kanssa samaa kieltä siitä, että kyllä ne huiput saisi lähteä takaa, koska totta kai he ottavat nopeasti kiinni ne heikommat, mutta kuitenkin, että he saisivat vähän niin kuin tää etumatkaa siinä, niin se on ihan hyvä systeemi. Kiitos. Hei hei.
No morjesta. Minulla kävi tämmöinen ajatus, että talvi olympialaisista voitais peruuttaa hiihto, että tämän sijasta me voitais kirjoittaa vaikka no kahdenkymmenen norjalaisten nimi paperille. Pistää nämä paperit lappuun ja sitten vaikka olympiakometian jäsen vois valita sieltä kolme norjalaista ja sitten nämä kolme norjalaista on sitten kultamitallisti, opeamitallisti ja pronssimitallisti. Tällä tavalla me säästettäis aikaa ja voitais vaikka luoda uusia lajeja, koska lopputulos on kuitenkin sama. Jees.
Alaillaan mo.
Vois olla tässä selittelyssä myös takana, että kun eduskunta vaalitha nyt vähän yli vuoden päässä, niin siinä on hyvä kansanedustaja aineista näissä niin sanotussa urheilijoissamme, koska se on jo sen selittely ja sepittelyn taidossa ovat jo täällä saatiikka. Sitten jos pääsee eduskuntaan, ei muuta. Kiitoksia. Hei.
Katsovat oli täynnä ja ne niiden kannusti aina oli sitten minkämaallinen tahansa kenellä hyvä suoritus. Edes se mitä mistä mä nautin kovana penkkurheena oli semmosia uusia lajeja, mitä yleensä ei ei näe normaalisti Suomessa. Aika harvoin kuunnelinkin oli tosi kiva kattoo ja sit siinä oli se asiantuntija, mikä hyvin selvitti aina mitä niin kuin kannattaisi tehdä. Samoin mä katoin kelkkailuja näitä hyppyjä tota noin ja tietysti ampumahdit.
Ykkösai ja sitten jääkiekkoo, kun se kaveri sanoi viime sunnutan kansanradiossa, että oli surkeat tuomarit jääkiekkossa. Se ei nyt ihan pidä tehdä paikkas, koska jokaisen maan valmentajat ja johtajat sarot oli tosi hyvät tuomarit. NHL:n ammattituomarit ovat niin kova ammattitaito eivätkä ne vedä mihinkä kotiinpäin. Se oli sillä ihan hyvin, että oli ihan mukava kaksi viikkoa. Ymmärsin erittäin hyvin kun tulee semmoisia tärkeitä lainsäädäntöjä.
Siinä päästiin haastatteluihin. Näinpä nyt onkin luontevaa siirtyä radio- ja televisioasioita koskeviin ajatuksiin. Ennen puheluita kerron, että Kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan joka perjantai klo kaksikymmentäyksi. Jos merkkaat sydämenkuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellonkuvasta, tehtävässä tehtävässä tehtävässä on se, että kansanradiossa tehtävässä on tehtävä, että kansanradiossa tehtävässä on tehtävä, että kansanradiossa tehdävässä on tehtävä ja tehtävä.
Niin saataina ensimmäinen tiedon kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Pulevardi on ainoa mistä tulee jotain aikuisten ihmisten musiikkiin ilman mainoksia. No nyt sinne on kun tulla joku keskustelupausto. Pikkusen musiikkia välillä ja taas keskustella. Mutta kun minä en tiedä mihin minä soittaisin. Minä soitin mutta kun sinne pitää painaa nappia sinne ja tänne ja minä olen aivan katon. Eihän ihminen ehdi aamulla istua ja kuunnella että mitä nyt tulee ja mistä te puhutte vaan haluaisi musiikkia.
Kiitos kuuntelemisesta kun mun harmittaa kun mä olen niin tottunut vuosien säätössä sitä kuuntelemista. Ja nyt siellä vaan jutellaan. Hyvää päivänjatkoa.
Radiossa sekä televisiossa eikö olisi riittänyt jos radiossa tätä kommentoitu eikä mennä niitten alueuutisten päälle että onko ne Suomen uutiset niin epätärkeitä että niitä ei voi näyttää koko kansalle että niitä pitää sitten kaivaa jostakin Yle Areenasta eikö näitä kommentaattoria jolla on palkka kymmeniätuhansia kuukaudeksi eikö niitä voi muuta näyttää?
Kuopiosta Terve Tantarajan kuuntelijat. Olisiko mahdollista että lopuksi kokonaan nuo euroviisut ja kyllä muuten kuunteleen kyllä musiikkia radiosta mutta euroviisut taisi kyllä olla. Ei kiinnosta ollenkaan. Tämä on vain minun mielipide että asiat tosaa olla eri mielipide. Huomenna alkaisiin kevään kirjallisesti kun on maalis-kuun ensimmäinen päivä. Kiitos hei hei. Ja kuten Pauli kertoi niin ainakin kalenterin mukaan kevät on alkanut.
Siispä on paikallaan kuulla Aallonlassan kevätruno mutta kerron vielä kansanrion puhelinnumeroon sitä ennen. Se on 08-00-15464 ja puhelu on soitteelle maksuton ja muistetuksena että sunnuntaisin kello 12.30 alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmisvastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Kuulinko ja vesisare sen tekee. Lumikinukset valuu jo veteen. Purot myös mukavasti solisee. Kohta varmaan hiekka pölisee. No mitehän vielä muuta? Alka olla aika vaihtaa suuta. Rakkaus useampia kiinnostaa. Sitä toivotaan, mitä halutaan. Kevämerkkejä seurataan, mutta linnuista jutellaan.
Meidän aarteista pidetään. Yhdessä hyvin eletään. Sitten värit kauneuden takaa. Upeaa vihreää luonto jakaa. Isot puut kaupungin kaunistaa. Lukat lisää kauneushuipusta.
Sinivuokon nähdä saa. Hyvän mielen jo siitä saa. Nyt tarvi unesta herään. Hyvä mielen hetkiä koko kevään kerää. Suosittelen saamaan teille toisillekin, että semmoista kevään alkua tässä toivotaan. Ja kiitos, eipä ei.
Nyt kansainvälisen naisten päivän hengessä kaikille naisille. Koiviston Lauri Kiittäjä kumartaa Kansan radio jälleen viikon päästä.
Ja minäkin olen somessa. Mä mietin vaan, että tapaako kuka enää kasvatusta ja livenä ketään? Onko kaikki tuolla somessa tapahtuvaa? Toivottavasti vielä enemmän tapattaisi liven. Ei mulla muuta.